Phil we're in LA right now we just got
hands-on with the Last of Us part two
long-awaited
it's kind of the kind of kind of gone
dark the past 16 months or so yeah
but they finally showed us a lot along
with the trailer and we played what hour
and a half two hours maybe yeah seems
like about that much to big demos like
one from the beginning of the game and
then one a little further in and yeah
it's pretty intense yeah I think one was
very story focused I'd say it was
I don't know spoil too much just in case
people are waiting for the final game
but it's Elliott it's Ellie with another
character and there's some combat
encounters but it's mostly focuses on
the writing between those two characters
which I thought was pretty good he's
blind [ __ ] make my skin crawl
let's make sure the rest of the building
is cleared out and then get the [ __ ] out
of here speaking my language yeah I
enjoyed it quite a bit it's a lot of
that sort of back and forth between two
characters that Naughty Dog is kind of
known for and that really makes the Last
of Us work yeah they're very good at
making just feel like a natural
conversation between two friends as
opposed to we've got to get to the tower
to do this thing even though they were
trying to get to a tower in that yeah
but you know they they joke and talk
like friends you know you were gonna die
let me guess you're gonna kill me
No maybe
[ __ ] you sorry within the second section
we saw which we'll probably talk more
about is the combat we had more weapons
it was called the suburbs and we were
able to experiment try out different
things one thing I noticed was how agile
le is compared to Joel yeah le is a lot
quicker and a lot more movement
capabilities now which we saw in the e3
demo a little bit like le can get down
on her stomach and kind of like crawl
under things she can lose people in the
grass when she does that not completely
like you're still pretty
you're still somewhat visible but you
can use that sneak around people a
little bit better and it seems like
you've got to be much more mobile in
general I think that's what you were you
were saying like you can't really just
hang back or sit behind a wall in in the
last of us what to not like you could in
the first game it's because of a couple
things right because one da I at least
felt smarter their money were
coordinated much more coordinated
aggressive and then the other big thing
are the dogs because if they catch your
scent then they will follow you to where
they will just keep following your scent
so that kind of adds an interesting
perspective to the combat right because
you can't just sit back wait figure
things out yeah you can use the listen
mode and if you do that you can see your
trail and the dog if it catches that
trail if it intersects with that trail
will start following it yeah they're
kind of tough to deal with is they're
fast they were hitting those dogs to
change it up quite a bit and kill one oh
man yeah that was that was a gut gut
wrenching shoot a dog and you hear the
owner of the dog just scream in anguish
yeah actually a big part of combat in
this game
is that the human element enemies talk a
lot and they talk to each other in
particular look into it
you kill a guy and you hear somebody
across the encounter go no Tom I'm like
and it's just like oh I feel really bad
about that
yeah the dev was just telling us one of
the deads the co-director was saying
that all the NPC's in this game are
named yeah so when someone dies they
will interact they'll be like they will
call out that that person died or they
might say like hey John the girls behind
that car or whatever and they could be
calling out your position yeah it's it's
intense because like this is a game
about what you're willing to do to like
survive and it's they've amped up like
the first game was a pretty brutal
experience and this is much more so I
doing especially when you pick up some
of those melee weapons like the machete
like oh man and and we kind of saw some
of it in the e3 demo but depending on
where you are the the kind of contextual
kills can change right and some of them
are very brutal I was throwing things at
enemies charging up to him stabbing him
with the knife and depending on where I
was that kill would look different it
was always look brutal and especially we
should choke someone out if you look and
see your face like it is oh yeah or like
not even chokes now cuz she's got the
knife now instead of the punching that
Joel had but I think the other big thing
too at least for the combat that I
noticed is because the area's seemed
more open at least in that second demo
it allowed for much more improvisation
yeah which works well right because
you've got the dogs tracking you the
enemies are smarter so it gives you more
room like I never really felt like I was
trapped in the corner if I got caught I
see a window I could jump off of and
then I could run behind the building and
maybe craft like a med kit and heal
myself and go around it all felt fluid
it definitely feels like you have to be
like much more on the move you've got to
be adapting then come be a combat
situation on the fly as quickly as you
can and even in stealth even as you're
sneaking around people and just like
taking one person out at a time you
really got to be on the ball scoping out
the area in and out of buildings back
around you know like hopping a fence
losing track of people maybe giving them
an impression of where to go and then
using that information against them all
the stuff that was sort of present in
the last of us one but much it feels
like you got to be like much more on top
yeah yeah it seems like all those
systems that were in place in the last
of this one they all kind of meld even
better together and absolutely you know
the game still has a couple months so it
comes out comes out February 21st 2020
yes make sure to stay tuned to games 5
because we're gonna have plenty of last
of us to coverage
thank you for watching thanks
[Music]
you
[Music]